each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay so my name is Michael Schmidt and I
work with Hot Lips in at Cornell
University and what I'm we talking about
today is a very specific topic I guess
this would be a majority my PhD work at
Cornell and some of my more more recent
results and all about extracting natural
laws from data so when you guys think of
the word natural laws what do you think
of anyone have an idea what a natural
laws can you wanna think of one you know
a natural law what yeah of course yes
exactly so that's a natural law a
fundamental law that we can write down
an equation that holds true over a
number of systems so one of my interest
is if you have lots and lots of data are
we able to grind out some of these
nonlinear mathematical relationships and
data my and some of these symbolic
relationships that are difficult to find
by hands it's very difficult to find
some use my hand so like to start off
with some quizzes for you guys so here's
some data plotted it's y versus X and
it's got this kind of u-shaped here so
if you're going to find an equation that
relates wide x what do you think the
equation would be give an idea what this
equations exactly so you guys are good
you go off to a good start here so
here's a little bit harder not too much
harder though so this one actually i'll
give you a hint no this one has a cosine
in it anyone have a guess what this one
might be sometimes a really really
really close yes yeah you got it
excellence so here's the once a little
bit harder think about this one for a
while this one's up
so you really did more difficult than
the other ones think we have any ideas
sometimes I'll give this talk to maths
groups and they'll get these like this
and I'll really have to really ramp up
the the difficulty of these questions
yeah in a way yes so Oh what kind of
function yeah so this is actually a
sigmoid and it's so you can see the
sigmoid just right over here so it's
basically just an s-shaped curve and is
modulated by this cosine right so this
is a problem that you know you guys are
actually surprised pretty good at
getting these right like you knew the
basic building blocks what was going on
but this is something that we can do
with an algorithm like that instantly
but you can imagine making this problem
much more hard say if it wasn't just XA
was you know twenty inputs and we want
to predict an output what's the equation
that predicts that one so that's much
much more difficult we can scale this
problem out through arbitrary difficulty
where it really pushes the limits of
what the human mind can actually
understand and do so what do you want to
hurt of symbolic aggression before this
term symbolic regression the couple of
you are not in their heads so symbolic
regression is basically you're finding a
model but you don't know what the model
is ahead of time you define the
structure the morphology of the model
and you have to optimize the
coefficients normally in this type of
modeling work you'll start off with the
known model for biological system and
you'll search over the parameters to
find the the best model so in this case
we have to fund wait to do everything
from scratch just like Einstein did it
come with the equal MC squared or
something like this so we represent
equations or what we're looking for in
our model this will be encode a model an
arbitrary mathematical model we can
represent these as a binary tree in
computer memory right so this is the
type of structure that will manipulate
to get to fit some data so our goal is
to find the expression the minimalist
expression that explains this data and
as we had different
we get we can evaluate this model and
see how well it fits the data how well
agree to the data how will it disagrees
until we converge on something that fits
it quite well so our ideas that they'll
optimize this this model make it as
simple as possible but also explain the
data as accurately as possible and
predict into cross-validated data is
that symbolic regression and typically
this is done with a genetic program or
is anyone familiar with generate
programming so a lot of machine learning
people will know what genetic
programming is this is an ideal
application for a cloud because it's
massively parallel algorithm where you
have you start off with a population of
in our case equations here and we insert
these into a cloud you're on this Jack
algorithm introduce mutation crossover
will vary and randomized these
expressions and we compete them to fit
the data so let's I'm sorry fitting
heuristic and you know we'll take the
ones that are better than the other ones
will throw away the bad ones will keep
the good ones we end up with hopefully
better equations and we repeat this and
literally we're going to repeat this
billions and billions of times so we're
going to search over most likely
trillions of a pic of expressions and
trillions of sets of parameters and
we're really going to exhaustively
search the space of symbolic expressions
to find Anna so our ideally what we want
to do is exhaust the search base this is
kind of a representation space where we
have the simplest equations over here
but the most accurate equations are very
very complex so we want to find the ones
that are simple and also the most
accurate this is kind of what this
preeto front looks like this front the
model so this one up here is perfectly
accurate but it's extremely complex it's
not very parsimonious or this one out
here maybe it's just one term it's very
very simple but it's not very very
accurate so we want to exhaustively
build this front so we can look at this
front and analyze what are the best
models that to explain the data we have
basically so that's our task and
souvlaki Russian so imma do something I
have not done before in a talk and give
a live demo so hopefully this works out
before I've never shown you this to
anyone before so this is some software
you've developed you can actually
download online if you're interested
talking me afterward but this is
basically a symbolic regression
application
together kind of looks like an excel
sheet here where we have our data and
here's just some pre-loaded data I have
and I'm just going to run this on this
computer so it's a little bit slow and
see what's going on so it's start here
okay so on the right here we can see
this is the data we're trying to fit and
the different colors are just if it sat
in the training set or in the validation
set and the the magenta couriers are our
best solution we found over this search
so far so on the left here we have all
the equations that are on this pre de
front i just mentioned so the simplest
equation we found that's that's very
accurate it's a single parameter model
all we have to do this kind of more
complex model up here right so if we
give this guy a few more minutes Oh
filthy a few more seconds we should see
it converge on to the exact solution so
does anyone know what this this equation
is what the what's the equation that
generates this one it's not too bad
anyone have any ideas this one's really
close its kind of bad down here though
so it's slow on this laptop as I'm
running the battery but we should
converge onto something quick here all
right this is getting a little bit
closer okay so now it's fit the the
general shape of the data right so now
we can look at these uh whoops sorry so
here we have the the best equation here
this is actually this is the right
answer and here's a losin this data so
these are very these are very very
similar but sometimes I an extra
parameter that's overfitting so the the
solution here is actually sine of 2x
minus x 0 sine of 2x that's what
generates this data and we can see that
this is the first the simplest model
that actually explains this data pretty
well or at least qualitatively well for
what we're interested in in the range of
data we have so that Wurth and so happy
so I don't want to say ahead of time
what you would actually it's hard to say
with a general rule you'd want to look
at each one of these because each one of
these is actually interesting result
right so this is the simplest equation
that's less than four terms in this
binary tree that fits the data the best
right so you might be interested in
different approximations so you as a
scientist you'd want to look through
this and see you know maybe you'd want
to test for afterwards it's just
parameter real or not and things like
that and uh so here we're just trying to
find the simplest you know for every
size of the equation we measure the
complexity of equation of literally if
how much space of paper does it take the
write down this equation right so we
want the shortest equation to piss that
out of the best and we want to you know
find the best equation for all these
smallest complexity of equations so
that's symbolic regression right so we
start with random symbols and so we have
a certain number of building blocks you
multiply addition subtract divide cosine
sine we have some sort of base level
alphabet to build up these equations you
could do that you could do that if you
have some prior knowledge i'd be a great
way to say i know this problem we'll
probably use this type of building
blocks long food these in the search and
it will make it easier on
this is a really mean this is a great
idea they and this is um that's what you
want to do you want to have you want to
balance your search over the the
morphology and the parameters and sets
right so there's a lot of research going
on now what's the best way to pick this
sort of balance and you don't want to
converge too early or your whole
population goes on the same model me a
very very little diversity in your
search but you don't want to do it too
slow because then it takes forever to
get these results and you may not find
the optimal unless you take the time to
really you know search through the
parameters also so in this case we're
just using the mean absolute value to
fit this data and we're just randomly
perturbing these these equations so I'm
going to move on if hopefully I do get
to what you're what you're interested in
and I don't um stop me I'll go over more
here okay so that worked well well so
there's a number of ways you can apply
this me not some of there is a I've
applied it or in metabolic modeling so
this is the largest system that's ever
been identified automatically with the
computer without using any prior
knowledge about the the metabolism yeast
cells and typhus so this is a seven
dimensional ordinary differential
equation system is it I'm a nonlinear
dynamical system so we find each one of
these equations and this is remarkably
this is almost exactly equal to what is
known a literary for this particular
system the exception of this term here
is approximated so we're able to
reconstruct the general morphology of
these systems pretty well you can go
through this and can see that you know
the rate of change in this chemical is
exactly proportion to what this equation
says you can build up kind of the middle
bulk network from this type of models
another useful area we found for
symbolic regression to solving some
difficult type of math questions this is
a new model that we've a new solution we
found to a very very
famous quit a question that colleagues
like the etham cells in the physics
community I know if you ever heard of
this before if you're given f of f of x
equals x squared minus 2 what is the
solution so sometimes just surrounding a
among faculty is a test of your
intelligence so we're able to use GP to
find a whole new solution to this and do
it faster than the fastest record time
of any physics professor oh well who
cheated us or the algorithm right so we
just use technology and so we can also
do other different types to check more
challenging problems you know finding
simpler models and what's existing in
the literature for a lot of these
systems is another area that we're
exploring so everything I've shown you
is doing a predictive modeling right so
we're building them all the system we
want to know what happens next how is
the system evolved over time how does it
change over time so I really want to
emphasize in this talk is proposing a
new type of a new way to go about this
sort of modeling so rather than building
a predictive model where I'm proposing
is why we look for instead of looking
for what what does change and how does
it change when we look for something
that's invariant what doesn't change in
the system and what won't change what
won't happen as a system of alts the
common opposite way of looking at at
this type of modeling approach so why
would you ever want to do that so here's
a picture of a pendulum it's just a
washer on a string and it's going to
swing back we might want to say you know
we could predict where this pendulum is
going to move how fast is going to move
and things like this but there's things
about this problem pendulum that don't
move can anyone or that don't change
over time this anyone know something
about this system that doesn't change
over time right exactly the Hamiltonian
of the system the the total energy that
does not change at all so that's
something that's not true just for the
pendulum it's true for many many systems
right and although we can use the
Hamiltonian to predict the dynamics
it tells us something deeper about this
type of system it's conservative right
energy is conserved in the system so in
some sense this gives us a deeper
insight than just predicting where the
pendulum is going to go it tells us
something that tends to hold true not
just for pendulums with other things for
example a helicopter engine right so
something like conservation of energy
also applies to much Patrol complex
system like this but this poses a
challenge right so a conservative an
invariant equation is just constant over
time so can anyone tell me you know this
say this line is your data what's what's
the neff of X what that that corresponds
to this type of data does anyone think
of one uh usually people a shout out F
equals 42 or something like that right
so that's a that's an equation that's
that's conserved for every system right
it's it's trivial in a way so finding
something that doesn't change is super
super easy right this F equals 42 so but
how do you find something that's not
trivial right so something that relates
to system variables but also doesn't
change so this would be a non-trivial f
of X right so it turns out there is a
way to do this and we found a way to do
this and we only get a really cool
publication on this in science but how
do how to search for and find these
invariant expressions automatically and
I'll get into how we do that in just a
second so this is our key figure in the
paper we click this nonlinear double
pendulum we get this sort of data and we
feed this to a cluster of computers they
grind away and is GA and they spit out
this is the expression that doesn't
change over time right tells you
something deep about this this double
pendulum so we go back here we can't
just fit data to anything because we
don't have a single we're looking for an
equation that doesn't change so the
inside here is we want to look at the
the implicit derivatives of our data so
and it puts a derivative or not how long
it's been since both of us taking
calculus but if you take the ratio of
partial derivatives you can derive these
implicit derivatives like this
delta x over delta y directly from the
data so we have a tent if we have a
candidate equation like the total energy
of an equation we can derive the same
relationship by taking the implicit
derivative and see the DF signal here
cancels out and we're using the f to
derive the same partial derivative from
a candidate equation as we have in the
data it's now we've a way of matching up
an equation with the data and justifying
a model from the data even for these
invariant expressions so the algorithm
that goes through this we start off by
pre computing these partial derivatives
we collect data we pre compute the
partial derivatives and then we go into
this search phase and this is something
you would also into a cloud somewhere
and we're now comparing this is the GA
we're comparing our population models
we're measuring our Fitness we perturb
them and we're going to grind away at
this as long as it takes to get some
interesting results and then we spit out
you know what are the most parsimonious
results that are invariant the most
invariance but also the most
parsimonious for your data so here's the
system we use for the science paper we
have this motion tracking camera and
there's me holding the this double
pendulum here and we have basically the
system uses these cameras it has these
kind of infrared markers on the spin
jelyn I know if you can see them here
they can track these over time at about
a thousand frames a second so really we
have a system that can kind of look at
some interesting phenomena in nature I
can actually look at itself and
automatically spit out the equation for
it so this is really a digital physicist
or at least as smart as like a freshman
physics student in college or something
like that right we have a computer that
can do this we can look at it and figure
out what are the dynamics of what are
the equations that could actually
correspond to this so this is kind of
fun to play with and I'll give you an
idea of how r reacts a lot people are
surprised at how complex this system is
just for being a simple two component
device and the reason why we chose this
system is this is a system that you
can't predict it's chaotic so this is
the thing about chaos is very very
sensitive to all neutral conditions and
your error increases exponentially as
you try to
the system but you can model invariance
of this system very very accurately even
know it's chaotic so even though this
thing is moving crazily you have a
really hard time building a predictive
model but we're going to show it we can
find an invariant model of the system
much much more easily so this is the
data that we get out of that motion
tracking for the double pendulum so if
you're the algorithm this is what you
see right and you're going to say all
right I have all these variables over
time how do I creakin bine these into
something that doesn't change and isn't
trivial this is the the problem we're
posing today the algorithm so we're
going to use the GA just like I showed
you before in the demo and here's a
visualization of the search and I'm
going to this is going to show the best
equation that's been found for the
system over time and you can see these
sort of evolved the quench is
represented is a an acyclic graph or you
can interpret this as a a binary parse
tree and the algorithm is evolving these
solutions you can see different
components sub trees are evolving
independently you'll see some
recombination where this part is
conserved only this part is changing
this is I'm an interesting way of
looking at how this GA actually operates
on these expressions that are
represented as parse trees like this and
eventually this converges down onto the
exact solution for the the Hamiltonian
the total energy of the double pendulum
and that search of the video took about
30 seconds so this search for us took
about 40 hours on about a dozen or so
servers quad-core servers so this is a
very data intensive search so another
way to visualize this is you know I
showed you earlier we're interested in
that the pre dough front the parsimony
of the equation and you know how
accurate it is so we can actually see
how the equation searches over this
space of equations also and you can see
the six block five minutes so you can
see that's actually searching down here
it's off the graph all the interesting
stuff happens up here is it tends to
find the simplest equations down here
that are very very simp
inaccurate and intends to build up going
to bloated solutions that can i recoil
back towards a simpler more parsimonious
solutions this is kind of jizeen if
you're interested in genetic algorithms
or genetic programming to see how the
solution actually comes about it's not a
direct route through this but has I
think this very indirect route through
the the genome of where you would
consider an equation to get it to the
exact bottle this is the exact
Hamiltonian up here at this is cliff up
here so this is the the the front of
solutions we get overtime for the double
pendulum and here the intensity here the
darkness is how much time did the
algorithm spend here so we spend a lot
of time on these intermediates
complexity solutions so we finally get
up to this this exactly just up here and
then we kind of grind away at more
accurate results up here so on this
front is actually kind of interesting
I'll hear all the equations first does
anyone know the what the total energy
foot for the double pendulum is any this
is actually a kind of a complex question
a complex solution so we can look up
here this is the exact energy
conservation for the double pendulum so
what's interesting about all the
equations on this is front these are all
different approximations of this
Hamiltonian equation with the exception
of this one which is another
approximately conserved result which is
the conservation of momentum of this
double pendulum so this only holds true
at really high velocities of where
gravity is negligible in this case then
this becomes actually approximately true
so we also find that you know there's
also these approximate Conservation's
that lie on this DiSpirito front which
is a very interesting result in itself
omega here is angular yeah oh yeah
that's I meant by conservation of
momentum angular momentum because we're
only looking at the angles on this
system the two angles here so we did
this with the number of systems and you
know when you search for these using the
implicit Dre
it is to get a different lots of
different results you don't necessarily
always get the Hamiltonian you get other
things that I can serve my kit
Lagrangian equations are the sum of
forces is constant over time if you look
at just a single pendulum you look at
the XY values you find that the circle
the radius of that circle of the
pendulum is conserved things like this
so I'm going to speed up here to finish
so I have time for questions so we did
some other systems 40 systems AI like
spring pendulum system this one's very
difficult to visualize because it's in
40s I'm sweeping on the variables here
but this is the results you get you can
model these surfaces and not just
predict a single values and trajectories
you can predict entire surfaces of
solution spaces and things oh and
finally if we repeated this experiment
with lots of different sizes of double
pendulum different masses different
lengths we can also show we also showed
in the paper that you we can find the
the equation for the bulk parameters in
this model the k2 is the K ones to
relate them to actual physical constants
and things like this so in the end
results we can get the full this you you
might think you pull this rate out of a
physics textbook or something like that
can get the full equation that relates
all these physical parameters of the
model with the Hamiltonian itself also
if we do this with multiple systems we
can pull out common terms and build up
how about an alphabet of physics you
know a library we can pull out the model
all these type of systems like the the
angular kinetic energy the linear
kinetic energy that the potential ever
spring the the potential of a pendulum
and things like this and we do this by
looking at the frequencies of different
terms we find all the solutions and we
found that terms that tend to be complex
and also frequent and these solutions
tend to be the most physically
meaningful so this is another preeto
space of just the terms and how
frequently appear and how complex they
are so this is a way of gleaning off the
building blocks for these type of
systems and doing a future modeling on
related systems so just like include I
have two points to make is if they use a
cloud to it you can use the cloud to
extract these sort of nonlinear
mathematical relations from your data
and in very models are useful way to
give you deeper insight into these these
systems than purely a predictive model
but if the caveat is actually more
challenging to search so thank you very
much so we can always well the one way
is to do an ultimate movie to take
another double pendulum refit the
parameters and see if it makes the
accurate prediction see if it predicts
that the the energy is conserved if we
see energy increasingly might get
suspicious here so the best way to do it
with cross validation and ultimately
these are white box models so we can
look at them and interpret them and see
if they actually make sense they're
immutable the human interpretation even
though sometimes looking at equations
can be confusing but for an expert they
can look at these sort of equations and
see is this is exactly what I would
expect for a potential energy term and
things like this so there's ways of
doing it intelligent later through
expert interrogation of the model and
also using cross-validation looking to
other systems that weren't used to find
the model and things like that
this it yeah this is exactly what I'm
interested in right so this double
pendulum you can look at you can see
it's got these arms you got these two
angles take a biological system you
can't look at these reactions and seeing
what's pushing on what and what's being
conserved exactly so this is the air I'd
like to take this and the only way to do
that is with testing their predictions
you find the best model and you test
predictions of Richard Feynman's famous
for saying this is what you do in
physics right you guess them all and you
test predictions this is a way of doing
it more with a more data-driven approach
so there's a potential there to do this
more quickly and accelerate the RA our
ability to look at the more interesting
questions or lease in the interesting
directions for that type of system but
ultimately yeah we have to test
predictions and then we might start to
trust it and publish it and what not
true
and that they kind of like right so that
would be interesting because it's you
could say this is a completely different
way of how a human would go about
solving this problem simpler so single
pendulums of course the interesting
result we have now is we we do have some
biological results where we found
conservation and we don't know exactly
what they mean yet so we have these
conservation for some gene regulatory
circuit so we're looking at and they're
perfectly conserved they predict the
dynamics beautifully all the implicit
derivatives and we're now we're in the
process of sitting down the biologists
and saying okay we need to interpret
this because you can't just publish an
equation we have to say you know here's
the answer but also here's how you
justify and interpret this answer so
really we're coming to this point now
where you know the computing can give us
the answer and the major challenge we
have is interpreting that answer so this
is the kind of next from three our
guests I don't know if I'll tackle it in
my work my PhD yet but I think in the
next few years that's gonna be a major
problem is interpreting the answers that
we were able to glean automatically as
these number answers we can get become
better and better and more useful in
useful
yeah so there's this problem a feature
selection right what's you actually ah
do you think you like you do that with
an optimization because that's even
that's another deep prot another deep
question I just what to what to
constrain to help your search right yeah
you're right that's an interesting point
very interesting thank you for your
feedback